bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous alors on commence avec cette
question les réseaux sociaux sont-ils
pro démocrate selon vous écoutez je ne
sais pas s'ils sont pro démocrates en
tout cas ils en prennent
dia blement le chemin comme vous avez
vous l'avez très bien raconté d'abord
ils ont censuré 30 lui même la fin des
tweets trempe
deuxièmement cette histoire de by dell
et de l'ukraine je vous dis ça en
passant
j'en parle dans mon émission de sud
radio aujourd'hui et j'en ai parlé au
moment de ce qu'on a appelé le obama
gates
on sait et a eu des sautes nord
l'histoire n'est pas nouvelle
l'histoire du fils byden employés à bon
rythme à l'ukrainienne à 50 mille
dollars par mois
il y aller ça je peux vous dire c'est
vraiment pas secret d'état il y a eu
plusieurs discussions entre le vice
président joe biden vice président
d'obama qui conditionnait et ses écrits
et dits enregistré lors l'octroi d'un
prêt d'un milliard de dollars de
l'américain l'ukraine au fait d'écarter
le procureur qui cherchait des boucs
l'attention de burdisso inter
il y à une discussion avec le divers
l'ukrainien les propres petro porochenko
et maiden et 7,7 a enregistré 10
donc évidemment nous sommes construit
une finale de l'élection présidentielle
cette histoire évidemment fait unis est
incontestablement quand l'honneur poste
le reprend c'est vrai que c'est quand
même étrange que facebook et twiter les
deux plus grandes plateformes de réseaux
sociaux la censure faut bien dire la
censure car tennis illégal vous l'avez
dit vous-même parti s'est jamais agi d
impôt ne
de donald trump qui ne baissait pas
pratique du tout censurer s'est
abondamment se répandre il ya quand même
un problème là le lot à mag et qui s'est
passé avec les tentatives énorme de
discussion de trois ans et demi le
rapport muller la collusion avec la
russie et ses amis se sont révélées ou
ce défaut ont été répandues partout très
bien et là au moment où ces by dell
tombent par hasard on censure ou bloque
alors pour suisse de mendrisio
oui juste une petite précision twitter
explique que c'est parce que il ya des
éléments piratés et des données
personnelles qui ont été publiés alors
écoutez si tous les éléments piratés les
données personnelles sont censurés comme
hyper sûr tout le monde qu'on le montre
j'avais très bien là dessus qu'il y a
deux poids et deux mesures
et par qui tu me poses de mesures il ya
dix poids et d'imagés c'est ça le
problème
le problème c'est que vous fait la même
chose monde des dieux sessions d'écouté
tout espoir de trump avant même sa
nomination façon élection à la
présidence il y avait tout un parti qui
voulait l'éliminer etc est destitué et
bien j'ai eu pendant trois ans et demi
ces pitres facebook sur twitter et dans
tous les médias je veux bien mais à voir
la tension joe biden et la gestion de
joe biden de la famille de joe raedle
d'y attaquer comme par hasard alors là
oui on sait pas c'est peut-être illégal
oui et les emails de hillary clinton dit
moi on a parlé c'est vraiment même si on
est l ennemi personnel juré de trump ou
détestent on ne peut pas ne pas voir
qu'il ya de produits selon le journal il
s'agit donc d'en
d'une machine de propagande est-ce que
ça va aller à la vente âge de donald
trump pour cette élection cette
polémique
bah écoutez tout ce qui se passe est
clair qu'aujourd'hui effectivement le
congrès en tout cas les sénateurs
républicains ont convoqué le pdg de
twitter
ce qui est intéressant dans le message
pourrait montrer une p dg de peter jack
jack dorsey ce qu'il dit c'est
inacceptabe inacceptable il fallait
explique t il dit pas il fallait le
publier il fallait expliquer pourquoi
c'était pas publiable incontestablement
on le sait les 90% des médias américains
je me à 1 90% des médias pour les biens
confondus radio télévision etc sont en
titre up à mort il fallait les son bail
d'un bon écoutez évidemment à ce moment
là est-ce que ça va peser qui commet
parce que tout le problème en fait vous
allez avoir c'est comment sera pesée le
fait que le train peut effectivement
dire regardez j'ai gagné qu'on veut
chorale amis russes ne pas avoir peur
les pas peur etc
côté américain que et qui met en scène
évidemment il est à politiciens y met
aussi en scène cela et byden qui lui est
beaucoup plus réservé qu'est ce qui va
peser
moi je crois je voulais mais tout
dépendra pour moi la bascule combien de
mes latino américains et des noirs
américains ni voté à 90 % démocrate
surtout pour les blacks américain
combien vont voter pour tromper c'est à
dire que c'est là dessus que ça va se
jouer dans les grands et a créé et qui
vibre avait ramassé dans trois semaines
eh bien nous suivrons sa très bientôt
merci beaucoup andré bercoff je rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste et écrivain
merci à vous